foreign
[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and
today is a cosmic queries Edition
on a subject I know we've all been
thinking about maybe not all the time
but sometime because we've heard it in
the news we've heard people talk about
it it's Quantum Computing got with me my
coach Chuck Nice Chuck hey hey hey
what's happening yeah you're gonna help
me get through this right
um yeah
I don't know help is the the right word
yeah yeah yeah so we had to we had to
dig for some expertise here and we we
found an old old friend of Star Talk
Professor Michio kako micho welcome back
to StarTalk yes glad to be on the show
it's been too long it's been too long
you've got a new book out this year 2023
let me get the right title Quantum
Supremacy
blood spilled okay
uh however quantum computer Revolution
will change everything so micho this is
a cosmic queries where we solicit have
already solicited questions from our our
patrons through our patreon portal and
but I want to just warm up a little bit
and just could you just give us in one
sentence what no
no yeah yeah exactly I'll give you a
little more than that so tell us what we
should know what com Quantum Computing
will do differently from regular old
computing
well computers have gone through three
stages uh the first stage was analog
computers when we computed on sticks
levers gears we returned the cranky to a
calculation with the Abacus was one of
those too right the Abacus a mechanics
that's right yeah slide rules right then
comes electricity so and the transistor
so all of a sudden everything becomes a
matter of zeros and ones zeros and ones
in digital and that's the computer
revolution of today now we are beginning
to enter the third stage in the
evolution of the computer no longer
Computing on transistors competing on
atoms this is the ultimate computer you
can't do better than that Computing on
atoms and that's what the quantum
computer is all about they exist already
they are millions of times more powerful
than our most powerful digital computer
on certain tasks so there's a race a
race between China between IBM Google
Microsoft a race to see who can get the
first all-purpose quantum computer to
put on the marketplace which will change
everything the CIA is interested in this
all the big uh commercial uh banks are
interested in this Aerospace energy you
name it
um everyone is interested in who is
going to be first to to bring out a
commercialized quantum computer that
could outrace any normal computer by a
factor of a million so by the way this
race uh you know
scientists among them but certainly the
military were early out of the box in
regular Computing right so and then that
regular Computing that finally sort of
Spilled Out of the military and Science
and Engineering communities and made it
to people's desktop and then their
laptop and then their pockets and that
clearly changed everything so so should
we fear this change relative to any
other I think that other change was
quite welcomed by people was it because
it was slow and we got used to it or
because we saw what it could do and
understood what it can do how would you
how would you characterize this shift
compared to the one we've all entered
and it's the military uh looking for
this for the same reason they did the
first computers that that we talked
about in the second stage Chuck what do
you think what do you think want to grow
flowers with it
well I mean we're talking about the U.S
pentagon dude I guess so God that's
that's that's frightening to meet you
where are you there well first of all
everyone's interested in the the CIA is
very much concerned about it because it
they are so powerful these quantum
computers can crack any known digital
code oh so this means that crown jewels
the crown jewels of Any Nation with all
their top secrets about the military and
defense posture all of that can be
broken into by an advanced quantitative
computer but of course everybody else
The Sciences in The Sciences are to say
because this means better cars Rockets
food energy we're talking about uh
unveiling unveiling the secrets of the
Big Bang the understanding of black
holes neutron stars in other words
everything is going to be affected when
we can multiply the power of digital
computer by a factor of millions to
billions so we're talking about a new
era in computation that'll change
everything you know it'll change okay so
and one last question before we go to
our and you got the questions lined up
Chuck all right they're sitting right
they're sitting right here I'm scared to
ask I know
I don't even want to ask him at this
point so so one last question uh we've
all heard of uh Quantum bits of zeros
and ones all right this is the binary
nature of classical Computing let's call
it that so could you tell us I've heard
the term Cubit could you tell us how a
qubit differs from a bit well think of a
spinning top like an electron that can
spin up or spin down this is one this is
zero and that's how electricity can be
used to calculate zeros and ones zeros
and ones now let that spinning type spin
in all directions
simultaneously so not just up or down
not just up or down but in between
simultaneously with all positions how
much more powerful is that than an
ordinary digital computer here and
infinitely more powerful paradigm shift
and these electrons compute in parallel
universes because these electrons are
simultaneously rotating in all possible
directions now you cannot be two places
at the same time but electrons can do
that and this is
powerful right that's right electrons
can be two places at the same time and a
quantum computer they are in all
orientations at the same time that's why
they are infinitely more powerful than a
traditional digital computer and who
uses this mother nature
because that's the nature of atoms
that's the nature of atoms and flowers
and enzymes of the body and cancer and
Alzheimer's all that stuff is at the
quantum mechanical level which is beyond
the reach of digital computers that's
one reason why we don't have a cure for
cancer for example digital computers
cannot model cancer quantum computers we
think can
so check out just to be clear uh Michio
kept sticking his right thumb in the air
do you see that yeah okay so there's
something called the right hand rule in
physics which was completely implicit in
what michio's gestures were okay so I
just gotta untangle that Michio before
we so if you put your thumb up right
right and curl your fingers okay all
right so if you if your fingers are
curling in the direction an object is
spinning right then your thumb is
pointing up right I mean in the in like
the North Pole for that object but if
you stick your thumb down then your
fingers are curling in the opposite
direction right that's right that's
right so that's how we in the decide
which way things are rotating for
everything in the universe is it
rotating with its with if it had a thumb
this is thumb pointing up I was going to
say yeah yeah it's a good thing pigeons
didn't discover this yeah who knows what
that rule we call it the different rules
I mean it's a completely different rule
yeah thumbless creatures what what kind
of physics did they invent meet you
all right so Chuck so let's start off
with some questions here all right here
we go plenty of curious people here on
the patreon portal sending us their
questions and we will start with our old
friend Violetta uh Violetta cool says
hello Uncle Neil Uncle Chuck
excellent she says this is Violetta here
uh Violet Aurora 14 and a half year old
astrophysics from Washington DC I'm
keeping it simple this week quantum
computers are said to harness the laws
of quantum mechanics to perform certain
calculations exponentially faster than
today's super computers what are those
calculations and what could their
technical applications B2 and here's the
rub specifically astrophysics
okay well I got into this Quantum
Computing game because I work in
something called String Theory which we
think is the theory of everything
including the Big Bang but string theory
is so complicated and so complex no
human has been able to use the mind to
solve it now when we look at a proton
how do we solve the mechanics of a
proton by hand no by computers lattice
case Theory allows us to solve the
properties of a proton we use computers
at the fundamental level so I think that
for the Big Bang they calculate what
happens at the center of the Big Bang
the center of a wormhole whether or not
time travel is possible whether or not
parallel universes can be visited all
these questions can be solved using a
quantum computer rather than a digital
computer which computes on zeros and
ones and zeros and ones and that's how I
got into it because I think it
instrument Basics there's so many
problems that cannot be solved with a
digital computer for example we know
that the sun explodes sometimes it
releases a Corona Mass discharge in 1859
it just wiped out Telegraph wires
throughout North America the Carrington
event
quantum computers may be able to model
that event so we can predict the next
Carrington event when the Sun goes
berserk and shoots a tremendous Corona
Mass discharge at the planet Earth and
wipes out all Communications causing at
least two trillion dollars in property
damage everything that's floating above
us satellites and all that crap will
just get wiped out including power
plants on the surface of the Earth we're
talking about a blackout a planetary
blackout we've never had that before a
planetary blackout where every single
nation on the planet Earth has its power
wiped out simultaneously therefore
there's no rescue crews no ambulances
because there are two right the entire
Earth is the infrastructure electrical
infrastructure is wiped out by another
Carrington event and we're helpless and
that's our show people I know much
it's your ass goodbye right so so so
meet you I I'm reminded that you're like
the king of disaster scenarios I just
I've forgotten thanks for reminding me
about that so so a couple of things uh
let me just sort of put some further
punctuation on what you just said the
sun is a roiling mass of plasma
with free electrons roaming among mostly
hydrogen and some helium and some other
Trace elements and there's a magnetic
field coursing through it that's getting
dragged around the surface because the
sun is not rotating as a solid object so
the magnetic field is embedded in the
plasma that Menard field is getting
stretched in all directions and then
there's a point where it snaps its
flings material with it and all we could
do is watch and meet show if we could
calculate all the stuff that's happening
there what a boon that would be to solar
physics so now is that is that the is
that different than a solar flare or
just bigger than a solar flare this is
much bigger than a software this is the
mother the mother of all solar flares
capable of wiping out all power supplies
in on the surface and in outer space
surrounding the planet Earth we're
talking about shutting down civilization
as we know it wow so it's a matter of
scale of energy
it's energy yes right and so and we have
evidence in relatively recent past right
160 years ago where this actually
Carrington event right that's what was
called Michio that's right even before
that 700 A.D 800 A.D this has happened
before again thousands of years ago but
we can now track these Carrington events
even into the past wait their their
Computing didn't collapse seven in 700
A.D what what evidence do you have well
how do you think we got got back to this
point this is
all this time we've just been working
back to this back to back back to ad7
how do you know it happened in ad700 uh
because several things the radiation uh
affected tree uh tree rings it also
affected the Arctic uh ice course Arctic
Ice cores oh of course they're looking
at ice cores and tree rings you can see
there was a disturbance in 700 and 800
A.D wow and of course there was no
electricity back then right so there was
no blackouts but if they were to happen
again it would paralyze the Earth we
would be thrown back 200 years into the
past think about it for a moment no
electricity no power plants food riots
no Refrigeration people riding in the
streets uh scrounging for any scrap of
food they can find right it'd be a
horrible mess and we're powerless but we
do know it happened in the past and
that's where quantum computers can
calculate we hope calculate some of
these disasters we need a backup plan to
to have civil civilization and restart
itself such as what we how we lived
before there was electricity right
that's right we are with my good friend
and colleague Michio Kaku professor of
physics of the City University of New
York and we're talking about Quantum
Computing as described in his current
book what'd you call it Misha Quantum
disaster oh Quantum Supremacy okay yeah
that was coined by a physicist at
Caltech all right it's his word we'll
get back to that when we return on start
talk
we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries
Quantum Computing is the subject and
we've got a man who wrote the book A
book on Quantum Computing uh Michio you
call it quantum Supremacy and just
before the break you said that that's
you're quoting someone who called it
that who was that yeah Joe preschill at
Caltech you see people used to think
that quantum computers could never never
rival a digital computer so Quantum
Supremacy is the point at which a
quantum computer can beat a digital
computer on certain tasks two years ago
the Chinese and also Google built
quantum computers that were millions of
times who are powerful than a standard
computer for a specific task the next
step is to make an all-purpose quantum
computer that can outrace a general
computer on all possible tasks that's
the race it's a horse race and right now
the Chinese and um IBM are some of the
leaders in the horse race but IBM is in
it I mean also Google is in the race
um Microsoft uh Honeywell everybody
realizes that whoever wins this race
will dominate the world economy oh man
I'm sorry but this sounds
this sounds very Third Reich
I'm just saying it's like we got this
race it's Supremacy you know leading to
a Master race it's crazy
it's a little nuts
but but Chuck is a Computing race okay
all right as long as it's it's kind of
it's that's right it's Computing
Supremacy that's right so Michio I
actually overlapped with uh preschool at
the University of Texas before they they
snapped him up over at Caltech uh he was
one who coined the concept and we we
actually made it two years ago and now
we're going for the next step which is
to create an all-purpose quantum
computer that can handle ordinary
problems problems of medicine problems
of global warming problems of food
production all the problems that cannot
be cannot be solved today using digital
computers or they could be solved but
they would take a thousand years to run
the program
regular digital computer to model the
electron wave function of a molecule
okay but that's what quantum computers
can do you know I forgot I forgot about
that we I think we perfectly modeled the
hydrogen atom but after that we just
have to approximate because the atoms
are too complicated exactly with all the
protons and the electrons and what
orbitals they occupy and and where what
the shape is I'd forgotten that Michio
because in the universe we're mostly
hydrogen so I I naively saw we got
hydrogen so surely you physicists have
the rest of these atoms completely
calculated but you don't because Chuck
hydrogen has only one proton proton and
one electron right and it's it's 90 of
the atoms in the universe yeah we're
good I never I never
pause to appreciate what you have to go
through Michio is a physicist so let me
ask you this it sounds to me like
something this powerful
um
could easily
achieve intelligence and then could very
possibly
achieve sentience so you know just
because you achieve intelligence doesn't
mean you're sentient but if you're that
powerful and that capable it's very
possible that you could become sentient
and now isn't that the scariest damn
thing that's ever happened since the
world has been created and Chuck that's
a different show okay all right that's
that's all right okay forget it yeah
that's what that is a different cell
you're right that's a that's an AI show
all right so Chuck okay so this is uh
Andre cebrew who says I'm sorry sir boo
who says hello my dear brain smoothie
makers
um he says as a vampire non-eternal
friend Andre from Romania I've been
trying to understand and put quantum
computers to good use in the following
hypothesis wait did you say non-eternal
or non-nocternal no on Eternal he says
how do you be oh oh so he's a vampire
that does die yes because Romania is the
original vampires I think I believe it
is just catch I'm slow I'm slowly no you
hit it you got it got it okay go ahead
then he says will come to will quantum
computers be able to map out and
transport our existential information as
entities so that we can live eternally
inside them and travel at the speed of
light between them so like the
transporter yeah beam your brain so
Mitchell we all know the complexities of
the brain and how many neurosynaptic uh
combinations there are and that's always
been kind of an intractable intractable
problem this question suggests via a
question that the power of quantum
Computing can simply map our brain with
perfect Precision is that in the future
uh well there is a program to digitize
the brain and there is a program to map
all the neurons of the brain right now
we're at the level of a mosquito we now
know that the mosquito brain has a
hundred thousand neurons every single
one has been mapped and you can Google
it and see what an insect's brain looks
like at the level of neurons a hundred
thousand neurons in the brain of a
mosquito and then of course we're going
to go up the scale it's going to take
time we have a hundred billion neurons
in our brain wait wait so it's that
number is not what's impressive what
what's impressive is the number of
connections right those neurons can make
and that's what you ultimately in a
mosquito how many neurons are there
approximately a hundred thousand and so
now the total combinations of connected
total ways those hundred thousand
neurons can connect that's a huge number
correct right okay so that's where the
Computing challenges not simply that
there's a hundred thousand neurons right
right right the connection is everything
right because it's the connections that
separate us from other animals uh other
animals have brains bigger than ours for
example okay but we have more
connections and more ability to do tasks
that certain animals do not have take
that you brick pain dummies
with the idiot Dolphins no brains and
your stupid self
ah when you see a quantum computer has
enough computer power to begin to model
these things a digital computer would go
berserk counting how many connections
you can have within the human brain but
that's exactly where quantum computers
Excel because we're talking about the
states of an atom how many states of an
atom are there infinite number of states
for every atom
not that zeros and ones zeros and ones
are binary which is finite that's the
difference between quantum computers and
regular digital computers digital
computers compute on a finite number of
objects zeros and one while the quantum
computer computes on simultaneously an
infinite number of positions of
electrons in other words Computing on
parallel universes so give us a time
frame when do you think we could map the
human brain and know every neurosynaptic
connection and the day we do can you
just beam that map to another place
thereby beaming your Consciousness or at
least everything stored in your mind in
that moment it was mapped
well I think it would probably take a
few more decades before we can map every
single neuron of the human brain because
there's a hundred billion 100 billion
neurons each neuron connected to 10 000
of the neurons in the human brain it
would take a while but once it's done
then the quantum computer can easily
easily begin to manipulate it and fire
away and create certain thoughts okay so
the problem is not the quantum computer
the quantum computer has more than
enough power to model the human brain
the problem is to slice up the human
brain slice and dice the human brain so
that we get all the connections of the
human brain map that's what takes time
that's labor intensity what we're
lacking are volunteers
that's really the problem here brain
volunteers yeah that's right
laughs
all right so it's still a little while
before that happens but the day it does
happen do you foresee being able to beam
an entire an entire person's uh is that
the same as beaming their Consciousness
just knowing how they think at that
point the quantum computer would have to
locate Consciousness within the brain
but once you do that why wouldn't you be
able to recreate it download it or
manipulate it and maybe Consciousness is
not a thing in the brain right it's an
emergent feature
brought forth because of all of those
connections yeah right I mean that's my
personal opinion that it is immersion
there's no one quantity that you can put
into a computer it emerges naturally as
a consequence of all the neural
connections Consciousness emerges just
as a byproduct of hooking up hooking up
everything you plug it in and it becomes
conscious basically love that okay next
one Chuck keep it going okay here we go
let's keep going
this is Chris Trent and Chris says hi I
have heard Michio Kaku say that his day
job is actually String Theory I've
always wondered when he shows up at the
office gets his coffee and gets to work
what exactly does he do
how does one work one string
yeah Mitchell is there anything on your
desk at all
a pad and paint see how it's a Chuck
I've always joked that a string theorist
the theorists they're really cheap right
give them a laptop maybe you know a pad
and a pencil and just just give him a
room and they're good to go so meet you
have we completely characterized your
professional
well when I was in the Army back in 1968
as a GI
I used to I read the first articles on
string theory and it began to play with
it when I was doing basic training so
dodging machine gun fire I would imagine
twisting strings in my mind and so in
other words it's very visual
these are real strings like violin
strings you can turn them around twist
them make knots out of them or whatever
and that's what I would do when I was in
the military after I get out of the
military I would write up the papers
okay and I would create something called
string field Theory the feel theory of
strings just like Maxwell's equations
there's a field theory of electricity
and aren't you the father of that whole
branch of physics is that correct if I
remember exactly okay
uh-huh so so Chuck you see he must have
known something in the mark did you hear
what he said he said as I was dodging
machine guns right see so he's got some
extra access to higher Dimensions there
right because the bullets were not
hitting
you were phasing in and out of this
Dimension exactly so Misha you're at
your desk and now what you sharpen your
pencil right and I go through hundreds
of pages of calculations this is tensor
calculus super symmetric tester calculus
on my desk is a pile of paper each paper
basically filled uh chicken scratches
because it takes a lot of brain power to
be able to write down all the equations
because these are resonances resonances
of strings vibrating in 11 dimensional
hyperspace and so it takes a lot of
paper to do that damn come on that I
mean can you just say that again I want
to get a t-shirt that says that
so now combine that with when meteor was
in the Army he just slipped it out that
he was dodging machine guns right so
last I saw that was in The Matrix
where
Morpheus is teaching Neo how to how to
be badass and Neo saying you mean one
day I'm going to be able to dodge
bullets and Morpheus says Neo when that
day arrives you won't have to ah and
then he's like what does that mean you
don't have to dodge them and my boy just
stopped the bullets and that's what
happens there it is I'm not even gonna
duck I'm just gonna stop so I think
micho has those powers and he just
leaked it on this show just now nice I
guess I'll demonstrate it
no free demonstrations no free
demonstrations that's right there you go
all right keep going Chuck okay here we
go uh this is Chris Henderson and Chris
says you know where they're from they
don't they say where they're from are
you skipping that uh no they don't they
don't okay if they say where they're
from I let you know I like knowing where
they're from okay or sometimes they'll
put it in the body of the question
um hello Dr Tyson hello Dr calculus this
is uh or is it theoretically possible to
make Communications that uses quantum
entanglement if
if it is would this give us the ability
for instantaneous communication with
distant spacecraft so he's talking about
Subspace Communications there's Subspace
Network yeah and Michio adding to that
I read because I only know from what I
read right about Quantum Computing that
there's there isn't the circuitry of
quantum Computing exploiting quantum
entanglement between adjacent particles
in the circuit board I heard something
about that so where where how does how
does quantum entanglement fit into
Quantum computing
well yeah quantum entanglement is one
way in which these qubits can
communicate with each other now you know
that in a digital computer
the bits do not talk to each other zeros
do not talk to one one does not talk to
zero they are independent when you do a
calculation not so the atom if I have
two atoms close together and I jiggle
one atom the other atom responds to it
this is called entanglement and the
question is well that's one reason why
quantum computers are so powerful all
the different kinds of qubits talk to
each other simultaneously then the other
question is do they talk to each other
faster than the speed of light let's
take a break there
and leave everyone dangling on a cliff
Edge
about whether we are communicating on a
circuit board faster than the speed of
light we're going to take our second of
two breaks here at StarTalk where it's
Cosmic queries with my good friend and
colleague Michio Kaka we'll be right
back
we're back third and final segment
Cosmic queries star talk with my friend
and colleague Michio Kaku Michio tell us
about your social media footprint how
can we find you
uh go to
uhmcockwood.org
m-k-a-k-u dot o r g I have about five
million fans on Facebook and the
internet and uh yeah so I'm definitely
on the internet okay and do you totally
on on on Twitter right you're you're
active on Twitter I thought I I follow
you on Twitter I know where you're
coming and and where you're going so
okay that's what we can do all right
Chuck you left us off with a question
about a quantum entanglement and whether
we can use it uh as a byproduct of
quantum Computing for instantaneous
communication so Michio what can you
tell us there
well it turns out that Einstein was
wrong on this question Einstein said
that you cannot break the life barrier
it turns out that these qubits uh will
actually communicate with each other
instantly faster than the speed of light
now it turns out I'm such an idiot he
was such an idiot well I'll tell you
what a dumbass that Einstein even though
Einstein was wrong on that that some
things can go faster than the speed of
light he has the last laugh
because it turns out that what goes
faster than the speed of light is
nonsense random information
Morse code cannot be sent faster than
the speed of light using the epr effect
e for Einstein
and it turns out that we can test this
in the laboratory we can now prove that
you cannot break the light barrier for
usable information like Morse code so
epr Einstein podolsky Rosen that's right
effect that was some experiment that
they proposed to test something about
quantum physics that's right let's say I
have two electrons that are together one
spins up one spins down see storms there
and get his thumb there so they are in
opposite directions okay and then I
separate them I separate them by a light
year okay if one of these is measured to
spin up then the question is what is the
other one spinning the other one is
spinning down because the sum of the two
has to be zero
it has to be either like this to cancel
out you have to cancel out okay but
before you open up one of these Photon
electrons you don't know what the other
one is but as soon as you know that one
is up the other one no the other one's
down now how fast did how fast did you
know that
instantly instantly finds it in the
speed of light on one side of the Milky
Way galaxy you know the electron is
spinning up therefore you know that on
the other side of the Milky Way galaxy
faster than the speed of light the other
electron spins down
that is the epr experiment and Einstein
thought ha that proves that it's all
nonsense it proves that all quantum
theory is wrong well we do these
experiments now Einstein was wrong
information travels faster than the
speed of light but it's not usable
information you can't send Morse code
this way Morse code cannot be sent this
way let's say for example that you have
one sock which is green and one sock
which is red okay you put the red sock
on and the other sock is green now let's
say you open the sock one day and it is
red
what is the color of the other song
green green how fast did you know that
instantly faster than the speed of light
okay you knew that sounds like you're
sending information faster than light so
but you see it's not usable information
you can't send Morse code this way
source code cannot be sent using socks
why not
I mean think about it for a moment
because as soon as you know that one
sock is red the other sock is green but
where did where did the message go
there's no message there
you're not saying so you're saying
you're saying you're saying that the
message is fixed therefore it's not
usable
I know it's random it's random and not
usable okay so but it but it's random
even though you know the outcome
uh well you don't know the outcome until
you reveal that one is green the other
one all the sock is going to be red but
that knowledge the knowledge of the fact
that they are opposite sides is
instantly transmitted faster to the
speed of light but try try sending Morse
code that way but so what you're saying
is but then maybe you misspoke because
you said you put on the green sock right
right and then send out the red sock no
no but you don't know that you put on a
green sock you just know you put on a
sock right yeah okay well then reveal
reveal that it's the reveal that we're
really talking about right yeah right
we're talking about the reveal the the
position of the sock existed before the
reveal but we don't know what it is but
once we know what it is then we know
that everybody knows everything she's
got it gotcha got it a physicist in the
making right here
we're gonna give him an honorary Star
Talk degree at the end of this okay all
right wow all right so it's not useful
all right it's not useful God so
disappointing no way to go faster than
the speed of like const consistent with
Einstein's theory is wormholes wormholes
will take you faster than the speed of
light and it is consistent with the
known laws of Relativity Stephen Hawking
even wrote papers on it now to create a
usable Wormhole is quite difficult you'd
have to have negative matter in positive
matter but in principle if you could
have negative matter and positive matter
you could go faster than the speed of
light in a wormhole and Stephen Hawking
even though Chuck he just said when pigs
fly yeah
all we need is negative matter yeah yeah
okay all right so Mitchell When Pigs Fly
continue yes no negative matter is very
rare instead of falling down negative
matter Falls up now when was the last
time you saw a rock fall up like what's
the last time you saw a pig fly okay
but if you could if you could create
negative matter you you could go faster
than the speed of light through a
wormhole all right got you okay and just
to be clear you're not actually you're
still not moving through space faster
than light you're kind of cheating in an
authentic Way by curving space and the
Wormhole then cuts through a passageway
and so you're effectively going faster
than light but you're not actually
moving through the fabric of space-time
faster than light is that that's a fair
way to say it right yeah that's right
you simply hop across yeah yeah there's
a hole there's a hole there you just hop
across how fast did you go zero zero
velocity right you just stopped across
right okay there you go and Rick and
Morty knew all about this exactly that's
Portal guns that's all we need all we
need
all right maybe the Atlanta will invent
one of those a portal gun probably and
we're good friends with her I think
she'll tell us about it first and then
we can like take over the world from
there I love every second of that yeah
Violet will be the world's over Overlord
[Laughter]
all right this is uh zagmund
vasik I believe I believe that's it
he says uh in Singularity I have been
told that mass could have infinite
density
can the algorithm of a quantum computer
resolve mathematically
Infinity I like that wow I like that so
make sure it seems to me that if you
take general relativity to its limits at
some point you're dividing by zero or
it's equivalent right so is there some
point where you say uh-oh general
relativity stops now we need some
different kind of math or more powerful
physics
that's right the distance at which
Einstein's theory of gravity breaks down
and the quantum theory takes over is the
Planck length Planck's length is 10 to
the minus 33 centimeters okay that's a
very small number yep and how would you
then manipulate something like this if
you have empty space and you could heat
it up heat up empty space to the plant
temperature then bubbles will begin to
form just like you boil water you heat
water water boils you heat space space
will boil at the Planck length or the
plug temperature and at that point each
bubble is a wormhole and each bubble in
principle can become a universe in fact
that's probably where our universe came
from our universe probably came from a
bubble in nothing and that expanded
giving you the big bang of today okay
Mitchell you keep talking like that
truck is going to run out and smoke a
joint okay
I couldn't wait to smoke I was like
forget it you want to boil the universe
this sounds like out of control we've
got the calculation people who do in
what is called inflation Theory have
calculated what it would be like to be a
God to create your own Universe of
course you want to do it safely you
don't want to blow yourself up in the
process but basically you boil space to
the point where space becomes unstable
you have Quantum transition what are
called vitamin diagrams that allow for
universes to pop out of nothing usually
these things pop in and out of nothing
all the time Stephen Hawking called the
space-time foam because it looks foamy
with bubbles percolating all the time
each bubble being a wormhole but one of
those wormholes just kept on going and
here we are
that's how the universe started we think
as a fluctuation of the Planck energy or
the Planck length uh his energy is 10 to
the 19 billion electron volts as a
distance is 10 to the minus 33
centimeters but that's my world I live
in the Planck length and the Planck
energy String Theory lives there me too
that ain't right to call us a
fluctuation that's right we are
evaluation
cherished universe is a fluctuation all
right there you go you're a blip that's
what you like
a fluctuating
no that's what we call them when you
write papers you write papers on Quantum
fluctuations of Nothing Even nothing's
unstable nothing would violate the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle pure
nothing is not possible right all right
let's get back time for a couple more
questions on Quantum Computing this is
Alan rayer and Alan says hello Dr Kaku I
used to watch your YouTube channel and
I've been watching since 2012. I'm a
huge fan uh I live in Lithuania and
could you please explain on String
Theory what force makes a Quantum string
vibrate it's string ooh and and are
there strings in the circuit boards of
quantum computers or they're just going
to say there's strings everywhere you
know it strings all the way down as they
say so how does how how how does
everything you know about strings inform
the people trying to perfect a quantum
computer okay first of all
strings have to fluctuate because of the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle pure
nothing pure motionless pure anything
like that violates the uncertainty
principle therefore strings have to
vibrate the lowest string the lowest
vibration of the string gives us our
universe our universe is the lowest
vibrating Octave of the string there are
higher octaves of the string and these
hierarchies we think correspond to Dark
Matter so that's why we have dark matter
because there's nothing but the next
higher excitation of a vibrating string
but again strings have to vibrate
because of the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle this is a quantum theory and
when the strings vibrate they create
subatomic particles mainly us we are the
lowest vibration of the string so people
sometimes say well can this yeah predict
our universe yes
that's right and the next the next set
of vibrations would be dark matter
right and one day we're going to find
dark matter and that could clinch it
people want experimental proof of the
correctness of string theory that could
prove it if we find dark matter in a
laboratory analyzes properties ensure
that it's predicted to be part of the
next vibration the next Octave of the
string okay so back to the question the
string in its natural state vibrates
because it can't not vibrate right
because because of the quantum mechanics
the quantum mechanics got it so now is
this exploitable in a computer circuit
in Quantum computing uh well the yeah
computer circuit would have a low
excitation of the string I mean a low
excitation of the electron but the
electron itself is an excitation of the
strength of the strength got it okay all
right there you go so Chuck do we have
one last quick question all right how
about this one this here we go Charles
macko or Mako he says
hey
what comes after Quantum computing
[Music]
I think that the Step Beyond Quantum
Computing is nuclear computing because
Quantum Computing computes an electron
shells we're talking about the electron
shells that give us the Bohr atom you
know electrons going around the nucleus
but the nucleus itself is nuclear and it
also is quantum mechanical right and
that in principle is stable so you can
make things out of it however of course
if you if you don't watch out you could
hit critical mass in which case that
would ruin your day
it would um destroy the universe yes
okay so it's interesting what you're
saying Michio is that all these rules
that we're talking about are electron
based and electron orbitals and all of
this electron spins but you can go deep
into the nucleus and there's a whole
other realm that is in principle in
reach that's right at the energy scale
of that is millions of times the energy
scale of the electron and that's why we
have nuclear weapons the nuclear weapons
in fact the sun the sun itself is a
simple example of what happens when you
tap into the nuclear fire that drives
the Sun and lights up the universe
that's what lights up the universe the
nuclear force yeah yeah so that could be
The Next Step Beyond quantum computers
would be nuclear computers okay so
Quantum Computing looks old and we get
you on the show in the old days Quantum
Computing we thought that was fast we'll
get you on for that and take us into the
nukes all right Mitchell it's great to
see you again and seen you since
uh great to have you back on the show
good so we'll be looking for your book
just came out Quantum Supremacy how
quantum computers will change everything
and no doubt about it from how you
described it it definitely will yeah all
right Chuck always good to have you man
always a pleasure all right Neil
deGrasse Tyson here of course Star Talk
another episode of cosmic queries
as always I bid you to keep looking up
foreign
[Music]